so when it comes to like actual anime
games
like games that are based off of anime
right which ones
have you done because we briefly
mentioned about the the dragon ball
fighting games or the narrator fighting
games but have you guys played any
recently i don't think so because the
only games anime games i can think of
that played recently are all like
mobile games or like catch games right
you know that
do they really count as games i mean
yeah they're kind of in a league of
their own yeah
i feel like that's a separate genre
right i'm a pure multiplayer slave
so i think there's like no anime games
in like the multiplayer
yeah because because the recent anime
game that i played
which apparently no one [ __ ] played
was the fifth of the north oh cause it
was a it was like a skin on a yakuza
yeah it was basically it was done by the
people who did the arkansas
and i mean i [ __ ] love this than
all-star so when i saw that and i was
like oh it's basically just a
yakuza game i was like hell yeah i
played it that game is
so [ __ ] fun i mean if you like no one
played it if you like the yakuza games
no but here's the thing i've never
played a yakuza game oh okay i've only
heard about yakuza games because
a lot of my friends yeah yeah yeah but i
was just more drawn to the fact that it
was a fist of an all-star game and it
looked
[ __ ] amazing i i i saw cliff he's
like yeah
dude you can do the omayo mushinder in
the game and i was like oh
yes so fun it's so good i love it yeah
but um did that get localized over to
the west
i'm pretty sure it does i saw a few of
my stream friends playing it okay
yeah i saw a few reviews when it came
out and it was just kind of like yeah
it's a yakuza game
yeah do you guys remember when when jump
force was announced
oh my god oh [ __ ] stole that course
that was hilarious oh my god
it was the beautiful irony that a a game
about anime characters
had some of the worst cut scenes
imaginable i don't know
i just i just remember the scene where i
think it was freezer or something just
like
floating up it was like t-posing it was
just like all right
guys i have to go that whole game is
jank
bro that's the problem with anime games
recently because
i don't know if the game will be out by
the time this episode is out but right
now i'm doing a video where i
collect a bunch of old retro anime games
that never made it out of yeah yeah to
like kind of
review anime games because like the the
general consensus i feel with anime
based games
at least in the west is that they're
very much a modern endeavor
it's like only recently that now anime's
becoming a lot more of a mainstream
thing in the west that
they're finally starting to capitalize
on the western market and
but you know in retrospect anime games
have been around since like
the nes super nintendo yeah yeah yeah
period they just never made it out of
japan
but it's so unfortunate that now all
these like people in the west who love
anime
are finally starting to get kind of a
glimpse into like anime based games
yeah and yet you get [ __ ] like jump
force and one piece world seeker
that one piece game i saw footage of
that oh my god the
frame rate was garbage dude i could i
was i was kind of looking forward to
that game too because i'm like
maybe finally finally we'll get a good
one-piece adventure
game no we did not i mean the problem
with anime games a lot of anime games
for me is they just look like
a quick cash grab you know what i mean
they they want to make it look triple a
but they're not willing to put the money
in yeah yeah
i remember like la i think it was last
year the year before there was like a
mahira academia game
they all looked the same they all look
janky as [ __ ] yeah
and yeah i i don't know like i haven't
like i you and then you read some of the
reviews and nothing really sells you on
this game versus this
hey this actual aaa game or something
that has nothing to do with anime
like i don't have enough time to play
games enough as it is let alone play
i'm not playing a [ __ ] game yeah yeah if
you're gonna get me off like the games
i'm cripplingly addicted to it better be
[ __ ] good
right right it better be arc nights
better be dark nights
breath the wild was one game that like
managed to tame me away oh yeah oh
everybody ever yeah the only thing that
tears me away from like league of
legends is another multiplayer thing
where i could just keep grinding and
yeah
i remember when i first played breath of
the wild because when i first played
breath of the wild was when i first came
to japan
and i remember it was it was great
because i was like it's my first time
experiencing japan
seeing all the stuff and all i can think
of is i just want to go home so i could
just
there's this part of the map there's
unexplored i want to hit that up i
remember playing in the bathtub
like i was so addicted that even my
bathing i had to be playing it i have to
utilize it every amount of time yeah i
remember i was i was in that [ __ ]
fire dungeon there the wind dungeon
thing yeah yeah yeah yeah
dude was terrible i recently during uh
at the beginning of quarantine i
decided to get back into uh breath of
the wild but this time i played it on
pro mode
wow wow you're such a gamer i know epic
gamergirl moment but
the only difference between pro mode and
regular mode is that on the
the main hud like you know how when
you're playing breath of the wild
there's like the mini map in the corner
like the temperature time of day
yeah yeah yeah pro mode basically takes
all of that away and just shows your
heart
right so you're forced to explore and
look around
and when i played it i was like this is
how the game's supposed to be played
because i discovered more things in the
first
because i discovered more [ __ ] in the
first 10 minutes of promo than i did
in the first couple of hours of regular
games because [ __ ] are you doing in the
regular game because in the regular game
mode you have the mini map right so
you're forced to like go to the
closest shiny thing that you see on the
menu yeah yeah whereas when pro mode
you have to [ __ ] look around and i
was like oh [ __ ] i didn't know there was
a temple right here
like right under my feet because i'm too
yeah that's true [ __ ] worried about
going to this tower that the the game is
telling you
he's pro gamer i was like
at that moment i was like this is this
is epic gamer girl right here